mr speaker this is the third time the
prime minister's announced a plan to
come out of national lockdown
in the past we've emerged without
sufficient caution
without a clear plan and without
listening to the
science we can't afford to make those
mistakes again this
has to be the last lockdown now the
vaccine rollout of the prime minister
said
has been remarkable and i want to pay
tribute to
everybody involved it is the light at
the end of the tunnel
but if we're going to get there we have
to trade very carefully
so i'm glad the prime minister spoke
today of caution
of this being irreversible of assessing
the data
and following the evidence those are the
right guiding principles
and i have to say it's a welcome change
from some of the language the prime
minister's used
in the past and i urge the prime
minister now to stick to that
turning to the substance of the matter
first
schools we all agree that the priority
must be for
all children to be back in school as
quickly as possible
and to stay in school we want that to
happen
on march the 8th as the government has
promised
confidence of parents teachers and
school staff will be critical
so can the prime minister please confirm
that the chief medical officer and the
chief scientific
officer support the full reopening of
all schools on march the 8th
and will he commit to publishing all the
relevant medical evidence on this
issue can the prime minister also
indicate what the government is doing to
overcome the huge logistical challenges
this presents the prime minister touched
on mass testing in his
statement but there was nothing on
nightingale classrooms and extra
capacity
this is a huge problem particularly for
schools with smaller buildings
so can the prime minister update the
house on how he's going to deal
with this in just over two weeks time
let me turn to a linked issue within
weeks of schools returning last autumn
thousands of teachers and school staff
were self-isolating
causing huge disruption to the running
of schools
and children's learning we don't want
that again
that's why we called for the early
vaccination of all teachers and school
staff
in my own constituency the fantastic
crick institute
which has been doing amazing work has
been vaccinating hundreds of people a
day
they've been very clear to me and and
publicly
that they could be doing more and it's
obvious to me that over one weekend
they could have vaccinated all teachers
and school staff in camden
if they've been allowed to do so and
without bumping anyone else from
priority list
there are similar examples across the
country so will the premise to see what
more can be done
to speed up the vaccination of teachers
and school staff
to ensure that children young people not
only return to school on march the 8th
but stay in school having returned
let me turn them to isolation support as
we release
health measures however gradually
there's a risk that infection rates will
go up the prime minister
made that clear in his statement
therefore it's
more important than ever that test trace
and isolate
is working and working well one of the
most concerning figures in a recent sage
report
is that only three in ten people who
should be self-isolating
are actually doing so and it's obvious
that one of the main drivers of this
is insecurity at work as the chair of
test and tracer said
people are scared to take the test
because they can't afford to
self-isolate
that not only harms our health response
it costs the economy too and it's got to
be fixed
we've proposed that the 500 pound
isolation payment
which is currently only available to one
in eight workers
be made available to everyone who needs
it
will the prime minister consider that
because if we don't
shift the three in ten figure there'll
be a huge hole
in our defenses third mr speaker
economic support
the prime minister announced a road map
today
but it won't have escaped businesses
that many of them will not be able to
open until
mid-april at the earliest and and many
until mid-june
i'm not questioning the health basis for
that decision which i support
but i am reiterating what we've always
said that health restrictions
must be accompanied by proper economic
support
and it makes no sense to announce today
that businesses will be closed
for many more weeks or months without
announcing new economic support at the
same time
the prime minister says well the budget
will be next week
but there's nothing stopping him saying
today that business rates relief will be
extended
that furlough will be extended or that
the
vat cup for hospitality and leisure will
also be
extended businesses are crying out for
that certainty
and the prime minister should give it to
them today
the prime minister should also announce
proper support for the three million
self-employed who've been left out of
all support for the last
year this morning on lbc i was asked
about this again
by a self-employed business woman who's
at a wits end at the lack of government
support
this road map means that she may not be
able to get
up and running again in her business
until mid-june
so surely the prime minister needs to
act now to close the gaps for these
three million
mr speaker we support the twin
principles that prime minister has set
out today
the lifting of restrictions must be both
cautious and irreversible
but i know the prime minister will come
under pressure from those on his own
benches
to go faster and to throw caution to the
wind
last week it was reported that around 60
years old members of parliament
called for the end of all restrictions
by the end of april i'm sure they're
going to be similar calls
this afternoon
i hope the prime minister takes the
opportunity to face this down
because if this road map is to work he
needs to listen to the chief scientific
officer
and the chief medical officer not the
honourable members for wickham
or the forest of dean if the prime
minister does
he if the prime minister does he will
have our support
and will secure a majority in the house
if he does not
we will waste all the sacrifices of the
last 12 months
thank you mr speaker